Speaker 1: Okay, so leaked decision,
Politico obtaining the draft decision,
the Supreme Court, unless something changes, will
be overturning roe v wade and Planned Parenthood
v casey. This will end federal abortion
rights. It will push it to the states.
Many states will outright ban abortion. I told you
yesterday, oklahoma passing a six week abortion
ban. That's basically a total ban. Most women
don't know they're pregnant until at least 4
to 5 weeks. A six week abortion ban is just an
abortion ban. So let's look at some reactions.
I want to start with radical Trumpist
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
She started crying when she heard about the
decision. Let's take a look at that video.
Speaker 3: I just want to make an announcement.
And I'm I'm sorry. I'm overwhelmed with emotion
because. The best news of our lifetime.
The Supreme Court has voted to overturn
abortion rights. There's a draft opinion out now
to overturn Roe versus Wade. And this is a this
is a great victory. It's a great victory for God
and and the unborn who have been innocently slain
for four years, for my entire lifetime.
And I'll just read this that says Roe was
egregiously wrong from the start. I just. Okay.
Speaker 1: Now, I think Marjorie Taylor GREENE is
completely out of her mind. I think she's
nuts. I think she's a horrible person.
But we have to understand, if you believe abortion
is murder, if you believe that getting an abortion
at seven weeks is the same as a cold blooded
assassination. It would be logical that you
would react like this. And so I think she's nuts
for a whole bunch of different reasons, and I
disagree with her view about abortion completely.
But let's understand that if you believe that
this is kind of a logical reaction, that the God
stuff is an extra layer, like without the God
stuff, I guess you could believe the same thing.
But so that's Marjorie Taylor. GREENE Laura Ingram
says to women who want an abortion, just
move to a different state. This was always.
Speaker 3: This was a state
issue and we have this.
Speaker 2: Ginsburg said it was shaky and bad.
Speaker 3: Well, and everyone has to remember
tonight, like before, everybody freaks out
that this is now going to be determined by you,
the people. Yeah. Like you can move to you can
live in New York and you say, look, remember,
New York did that standing ovation. And Albany,
you want to know what's sick is it's not safe,
legal and rare anymore. In New York,
you get a standing ovation for having
abortion up until basically the baby is out.
Speaker 1: Of the womb. Okay. So the reality,
of course, is a lot of people can't afford
to move. I mean, listen, the same people
who might be in a situation where they might want
to seek an abortion and they would have trouble
paying for that. You think they can afford to move
to a different state in order to get it? I mean,
that doesn't make any sense whatsoever. Now, Laura
Ingram is aware that there are some on the left
saying maybe this will inspire the left to get out
and vote in November and it could save the midterm
for Democrats. She doesn't agree, though.
Speaker 3: The left is going into the
stratosphere tonight. They're going nuts.
They know their entire facade. Everything
they fought for. This is the die that the hill
that they'll die on. They're worried that it's.
Speaker 1: All going to come.
Speaker 3: Crumbling down.
And they think that that somehow this leak is
going to be a gift that could rescue them for
the midterms. Well, the thinking is misguided.
Speaker 1: All right. So Laura Ingram says this
won't save Democrats in November. Republican
Trumpist Congresswoman Lauren Boebert put out
a tweet in response saying, If your response to
the Supreme Court news is to dust off your stupid
pink hat from 2016 and go march to a support
infanticide, reevaluate your entire life. And
then lastly, Fox host Tomi Lahren says Democrats
are going to do their own insurrection over this.
Speaker 3: Talking about this leak, do you
think that this was an intimidation tactic?
Absolutely. And intimidation tactic and also a
distraction tactic here. I think that the only
way the Democrats have a chance in November is if
they rile everybody up, get people to the polls
with these emotional, cultural issues, of course.
Speaker 1: Now, what's funny about that is it's
Republicans who use contrived cultural issues to
get people to the polls like critical race theory.
This issue of abortion is a real issue.
It's about precedent. It's about law.
It's actually about a Supreme Court decision.
When you have the Supreme Court actually
dealing with something, it's not a contrived
issue. The contrived issues are on their side.
Speaker 3: Abortion is one that's going to be
very high emotion, very intense for the country.
This is their effort to distract from everything
that's going wrong and play to the heartstrings of
those, especially on the left. This this issue is
so important, too. And I think we're going to see
the summer of 2020 reignited with protests
and, dare I say, an insurrection. I know
that's a dirty word, but I think we're
going to see a lot more to come this week.
Speaker 1: I don't believe that we are going to
see an insurrection or a coup attempt. I think
we will hopefully see Democrats say, wow, look
at what the it it took a few years, right? It
was I don't know. Trump, Hillary, I don't know.
And then here's Trump and he gets one pick to
the court and then he gets a second pick and then
he gets a third pick. And then Mississippi says,
we're going to ban abortion. And it's appealed,
appealed, appealed. And then it goes to the court
and well, we'll hear from the court at some point.
And the court says Roe v Wade is gone, folks. Roe
v Wade is gone. That's it. It took some years,
but that's the way it ultimately worked. Let me
know if you believe this changes the outlook for
the midterms. Find me on Twitter at David Pakman.